Welcome to Bible Answers Live, where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions.
Let's face it, it's not always easy to
understand everything you read in the
Bible. With 66 books and more than
700,000 words, the Bible can generate a
lot of questions. If you'd like answers
to your Bible questions, you've come to
the right place. Now, here's your host,
Pastor Doug Batchelor, president and
speaker of Amazing Facts.
Hello friends. Would you like to hear an
amazing fact?
August 2016, it was announced that a
fisherman in the Philippines discovered
what is probably the world's largest
pearl.
The man found the immense pearl within a
giant clam while diving off of Puerto
Princesa City on the island of Palawan.
Now, catch this.
The monstrous mineral measures 2.2 ft by
1 ft and weighs 75 lb.
This greatly surpasses the former record
of 14 lb.
Now, keep in mind this pearl is not
round, but shaped more like a giant
glazed croissant.
Even more incredible, the man discovered
the pearl in 2006,
then stored it under his bed and forgot
about it for 10 years until he had to
move.
Now, its true record-breaking value is
coming to light.
You know, the Bible talks about pearls
that are so humongous that the gates of
heaven are made from a single specimen.
Stay with us, friends. We're going to
learn more as Amazing Facts brings you
this edition of Bible Answers Live.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live,
honest answers to your Bible questions.
Our phone lines are now open. If you
have a Bible-related question, call us
at 1-800-463-7297.
Let's get to our first Bible question
with Pastor Doug Batchelor and our
co-host, Pastor Jean Ross.
Hello listening friends. Welcome once
again to Bible Answers Live. And as you
probably gathered from the title, this
is a live opportunity for you to ask
Bible questions. Just pick up the phone
give us a call. We have several lines
open right now. Good chance you'll get
your call on tonight's program. That
number is 800-God says. That's
800-463-7297.
And
one more time, 800-463-7297
brings your phone call into the studio
with your Bible questions. My name is
Doug Batchelor. My name is Jean Ross.
Good evening, friends. And Pastor Doug,
before we go to the phone lines, let's
start with prayer.
Dear Father, once again, we thank you
that we can take a few moments to study
the word together. And we ask your
special blessing upon this program this
evening. Be with those listening, Lord.
And as we open the scriptures, we ask
that the spirit would lead us into a
fuller understanding of your will for
our lives. For we ask this in Jesus'
name. Amen. Amen. Well, Pastor Doug, you
opened the program talking about this
incredible find, a pearl. It's almost
hard to imagine a pearl that was over 2
ft.
Can you imagine trying to make that into
a necklace and
wear that around your neck?
Uh, but it's just a gigantic pearl. You
wonder what the value of something like
that is. Well, they're still going to
bring in a gemologist that will
authenticate its size. It's It's been
pretty well substantiated by uh, just
the the people in the region and leaders
in the community. Um, it's not uncommon
to find giant pearls in the giant clams
around that part of the Philippines.
They're some of the largest in the
world. But, um, its value, I guess, is
still remains to be determined. The
thing that struck me was, and you can
see pictures of this online, it does
look like a a giant beautifully glazed
croissant. It's kind of elongated and
it's it's kind of strange-looking. But,
I'd hate to have been the clam that
would had that growing inside. And if it
says in in the Bible, when it describes
some of the glories of heaven, and it
talks about the the foundation of the
city made of precious gems and the
streets of gold and the gates of pearl,
uh, people have said, "Well, you know,
those are just metaphors."
But, uh, keep in mind the Bible says,
and you can read about this in in 1
Corinthians 2:9,
"The eye has not seen nor the ear heard,
neither has even entered into the heart
or the imagination of man the things
that God has prepared for those that
love him." We can't even imagine it. And
you think about some of the incredible
things in the world that God has made
that we can see, we shouldn't be shocked
by things that God declares he will have
in the world to come. Nothing is
impossible for God. And you know, people
always wonder, "How could you get a
pearl big enough to make a gate
that people can walk through?"
And well, you know, now it's becoming
more believable. Well, if you can have a
75-lb pearl found, uh,
there off the Philippines. And the Lord
wants you in that city. Friends, you
might be thinking that what the Bible
says about that city is just too good to
be true or just too fantastic to
believe, but it is very real. And
there's a lot more detail in the Bible
that tells you about the reward for the
redeemed and the earth made new. And
we'd like to send you this copy. If you
want to be encouraged, read some of the
promises that God has made. Jesus said,
"Blessed are the meek, for they will
inherit the earth." But, what an earth
it's going to be. Take a look. And we'll
send you a free offer on that. We have a
study guide this evening. It's called a
colossal city in space. And it's talking
about the New Jerusalem, the place that
God is preparing for those that love
him. We'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls and asks. The number
to call is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the study guide called a
colossal city in space. Once again, that
number is 800-835-6747.
And if you have a Bible question, the
phone line here to the studio is
800-463-7297.
800-God says. That's 463-7297.
We're going to go to the phone lines.
Our first caller this evening is, um,
Michael listening from Henderson,
Kentucky. Uh, Michael, welcome to the
program.
Hello, Pastor Doug. How are you?
Doing well. Thank you for your call. And
how can we help you tonight?
Yes, my question is, what is the second
What is the second coming and why is it
important?
Well, first of all, in sequence, it's
called the second coming because the
first time that Christ came to our world
was as a man, as a baby. He pretty much
came as a lamb.
Uh, John the Baptist said, "This is the
lamb that takes away the sin of the
world." He was our sacrifice. He was our
example. But, he's coming next time to
take possession. He's coming as a lion.
He's coming as a king.
And he's going to put an end to
rebellion and sin and the devil. Devil's
bound at the time when Christ comes.
There's a resurrection.
And, uh, those who are alive when the
Lord comes will be caught up to meet him
in the air. And they're transformed and
given glorified bodies.
And you find that in 1 Corinthians 15
and 1 Thessalonians chapter 4.
But, would you like We have a free study
guide that deals with the themes of the
second coming. And we'll be happy to
send you one if you'd like that,
Michael.
Well, do you have the, uh, Day of the
Lord magazine?
We do. I think we could probably send
you one of those. They're hot off the
press.
I hadn't even thought of that.
that.
Yeah, we'll be happy to send you one.
So, we'll we'll just make a note. You
call the number Pastor Ross is going to
give and say that you were listening to
Bible Answers Live and we promise to
send you a Day of the Lord magazine.
Again, that number to call, Michael, is
800-835-6747.
You can ask for our new magazine talking
about the second coming called the Day
of the Lord. We also have a website that
goes along with, uh, the subject of the
second coming. It actually goes along
with the new magazine. And it's called
rapturetruth.com.
Again, that website is just simply
rapturetruth, all one word, .com.
That'll take you to our brand new
website that's filled with all kinds of
great resources. There's video there as
well, a number of scriptural references.
So, surely take a look at that. Again,
that website is just simply
rapturetruth.com.
Our next caller is David and he's
listening right here in Sacramento.
David, welcome to the program.
Hello.
Hi, David. You're on. Your question
tonight.
My question is about Revelation 20:5.
verse 5.
It goes, "The rest of the dead did not
come to life until the thousand years
were ended. This is the first
resurrection."
How can the first resurrection
ever possibly be
involved with the rest of the dead? I
thought the rest of the dead were all
the lost people of all time. All right.
Well, let me answer that for you. This
is telling us that the, um, when the
Lord comes, that, uh, the dead in Christ
are caught up, they meet him in the air.
It says, "Blessed and holy is he that
has part on the first resurrection." So,
that's what happens in the first
resurrection.
The rest of the dead are the ones who
are in the second resurrection.
And they don't live again till the
thousand years are finished. And you
read that in verse, um,
yeah, it's verse 3.
It says there that the rest of the dead,
if the righteous are the first ones
raised, who's left? The wicked. So, the
rest of the dead don't live until the
thousand years are finished. Yeah, you
know, that is an interesting verse,
verse 5. That phrase in particular that
says, "But, the rest of the dead did not
live again until the thousand years are
finished. This is the first
resurrection." The first resurrection is
not talking about those who didn't live
again until the thousand years are
finished. Actually, if you go back to
verse 4, it's talking about those who
live and reign with Christ for a
thousand years. And those are the ones
who are resurrected in the first
resurrection. So, it's still talking
about the first resurrection. And then
it answers the question, well, what
happens to the rest? Well, they're not
going to live until the thousand years
is finished. And then he finishes up on
that thought of the first resurrection.
So, I know it's confusing in verse five
in particular, but the phrase "the rest
of the dead did not live again till the
thousand years are finished." That's not
connected with the first resurrection.
Yeah, Paul is just closing off his first
thought by saying this is the first
resurrection, meaning the ones that come
forth in the in the
who live and reign with Christ for a
thousand years. Yep. Hey, we appreciate
your question, David, and we have that
uh website you'll enjoy. Also, we can
send you our special offer for tonight.
That's right. It's talking about a
colossal city in space. We also have a a
matter of I just thought of that now,
two pastor Ed. We do have a study guide
that deals specifically with the
thousand years, the millennium, called A
Thousand Years of Peace. And we can send
that to you as well, David. The number
to call is 800-835-6747.
Ask for the study guide called A
Thousand Years of Peace, and we'll be
happy to send that to you. And then, of
course, take a look at our new website,
rapturetruth.com.
We have Jamie listening in West
Frankfort, Illinois. Jamie, welcome to
the program.
Hello. Thank you for having me.
We're glad you called. And your question
tonight?
Um okay. So, I'm basically I I'm almost
there, but I've been struggling with
practically with all of
the New Testament, everything that
Apostle Paul
um
is teaching. And you may get this a lot
um for newcomers.
Yep.
But Paul's teachings, I I get there and
I believe everything. And then I keep
going into Paul's teachings, like in
Hebrews chapter 8 through 10.
Um
you know, Romans chapter 14.
Basically talking about
you know, when he got mad at the Jews
for, you know, wanting the Gentiles to
to keep the laws to please God. And And
he just talks about all that quite a bit
in the New Testament.
Yeah.
Um
And I'm just trying to figure out where
you guys come from on that, you know,
how do you
what you make of it because it it's hard
for me at each time I read the New
Testament, I keep thinking, well, we are
free and Christ is enough to not have to
obey these
commandments in that type of way. All
right. Well, let's see what we can Let's
see what we can cover here, Jamie. First
of all, don't feel bad. Even the Apostle
Peter said, "Sometimes Paul" and this is
2 Peter chapter 3, I think it starts
with verse 15, "Sometimes Paul says
things that are hard to understand."
Knowing who Paul is writing to, a lot of
what Paul is doing is he's dealing with
the problem of the Jewish converts to
Christianity telling the new Gentile
converts around the Roman Empire, "You
need to keep all these ceremonial laws."
And Paul had to spend quite a bit of
time saying, "Jesus was the lamb. We
don't need the sacrificial system
anymore. Circumcision was a covenant of
Abraham promising that the seed, the
Messiah, would come through his
descendants." He said, "That's not
necessary cuz Jesus is the lamb. Jesus
fulfilled the seed of Abraham."
Right.
But that doesn't mean the Ten
Commandments, which were given, they're
for all men.
Um and you know, when God spoke his
covenant, we're all saved uh based on
the new covenant.
And the old covenant was the Ten
Commandments written on stone. The new
covenant is the Ten Commandments written
on the heart. But the the the law is
still there. You know, Jesus made it
pretty clear, "Thou shalt not commit
adultery." Well, once you become a
Christian, it's not suddenly okay to
commit adultery.
Right.
And you know, we can't lie, we can't
steal, we shouldn't pray to idols. The
New Testament is very clear on idolatry.
John says, "Keep yourself from idols."
So, the Ten Commandments is called the
moral law.
Uh even, you know, way back in the days
of Cain, when there was no Jew or no
Gentile, murder was wrong and God called
murder a sin.
And when Joseph was tempted to sleep
with someone else's wife, he called it a
sin.
Adultery was a sin. And so,
those commandments are, you know, part
of the law of love.
Yeah, you know, it's interesting in the
Old Testament, you know, Paul's talking
about various laws in the Old Testament.
The Old Testament law is divided up
roughly into four categories. You have
the moral law, as pastor Ed mentioned,
the Ten Commandments, which really
define what sin is. Sin is the
transgression of the law, the Ten
Commandments. You also have the
ceremonial law that had to do with the
sacrificial system and certain services
associated with the sanctuary. And all
of them All of those services and those
laws pointed forward to Jesus. Then you
have some health principles that we find
in the Old Testament, which were given
so that we could be healthy. God wants
us to be um you know, our bodies are the
temple of the Holy Spirit. Take care of
these bodies. And then you have some
civil law, which helped to govern the
nation of Israel under theocracy. So,
when you look at those four clusters of
law, the moral law is definitely binding
today. The ceremonial law, which pointed
forward to Christ, that was fulfilled
when Jesus came. And that's sort of the
burden of what Paul is saying. But there
are health principles that are true
today. And for those who follow those
health principles, they live a healthy,
stronger life. And then the civil laws,
nations that follow those principles,
typically tend to do better than those
who don't. So, those are the four
families of law that we find.
Yeah, and we Jamie, you still there?
Yeah, I'm I'm here. We have a lesson
of that. Yeah, we have a lesson we can
send you on the law that we'll send you
a free copy if you'd like that.
Uh yep. Well, so what was your question
when you talked about Paul's writings?
Was it principally about the law?
Yeah, it's just it seems like he
I I just I get there and then it's
almost like, okay, I know that we're not
supposed to lie, but even if if we're a
believer and we don't keep these
commandments, Christ is still enough
to I don't know. Yeah, well, you know,
of course, if we sin, the Bible says,
"If any man sin, we have an advocate
with the Father." So, uh if a believer
sins, we repent, we tell the Lord we're
sorry, we uh turn to Jesus and believe
that he's forgiven us. Bible says, "If
we confess, he is faithful and just to
forgive us and cleanse us from all
unrighteousness." But if we love the
Lord, we should never feel good or
comfortable about sinning.
Yep.
Yeah, cuz, you know, sin is what nailed
Jesus to the cross. So, that of course
should pain us as well.
You just one additional thought on that.
If you have a child that, you know,
they're growing up and they're learning
and they take something that they're not
supposed to take, they steal, and you
confront them on the issue and they say,
"Oh, I'm sorry." And they they realize
the error of their ways, you're not
going to kick them out. But if there is
ongoing theft all the time and they keep
stealing, well, that's evidence that
there is a deeper problem that has to be
dealt with. And so it is with the law of
God. It's not the occasional time that
we break God's commandment, but if we
are looking for an excuse to continually
break God's law, well, then that's
evidence that there might be a deeper
problem that has to do with the heart.
Mhm.
Now, we'll send you that free lesson
that talks about the law of God. It's
called Written in Stone, and it also
talks about his love as well as his law.
The number to call is 800-835-6747.
That is the resource phone line number,
and you can ask for that study guide
called Written in Stone, and we'll be
happy to send that to you, Jamie, or
anybody who calls and asks. Again,
that's 800-835-6747.
The phone line here at the studio with
your Bible question is 800-463-7297.
800-463-7297.
Let's see. Our next caller is Rita
listening from New York, New York. Rita,
welcome to the program.
Hi. Um yes, my question is on the
Sabbath day. Okay.
Uh the Bible says that that's to
remember the Sabbath day and keep it
holy. And that day is what?
It says in the commandment, if you look
in both uh I'm sorry, Genesis chapter 2
and in Exodus chapter 20 verse 8, it
says that the seventh day God rested
from all his work which he created and
made. And so, there's nothing that could
be more clear and emphatic in the Bible
that God says, "I blessed the seventh
day. I hallowed it." So, it's the
seventh day, which is the Sabbath.
Which is Saturday, Yeah, it's the same
day that God gave to the Jewish nation.
Right. So, why is it that
you have most
church goers on Sundays? Who changed it
to Sunday? Well, that's a good question.
You can't find Bible evidence for that.
Uh some people point to uh some meetings
that evidently happened on the first day
of the week, and they say this is proof
of a new commandment. But there is no
commandment you can point to in the
Bible to keep the first day or the third
day. The only commandment you can point
to is to keep the seventh day holy. Now,
we're not saved. Yeah, you know, we
should worship God every day of the
week. But not every day is a day of
rest.
Right, but the commandment says to
remember the Sabbath day and to keep it
holy. And also in Revelation, it talks
about we can't add or take anything away
from the Bible. Yeah, not without day.
Right, without grave consequences anyway
trying to do that. And it even goes on
to say, "The beast power" if you look in
Daniel chapter 7:25, it says, "He He
will think to change times and laws."
And so, yeah, you're Sounds like you're
on the right track. But now, of course,
there's a lot of sincere Christians that
go to church on the first day, and many
of them they call it the Lord's Day. And
nowhere in the Bible does it say that
the first day of the week is the Lord's
Day. It's just sort of an assumption
that's made. Um and you know, we're not
saying that people who have previously,
you know, spent their Christian
experience going to the church on Sunday
are lost. But if you want to be
biblically accurate, it's hard to prove
any other day than the seventh day as
the Sabbath. You know, we do get a lot
of questions on this and it seems like
there's a lot of Christians that are
coming to a clear understanding on this
question on the Sabbath. We have a
website called sabbathtruth.com.
And it gets into some uh scripture
references. There's some videos there
talking about this subject. And for
anyone listening who wants to learn more
about uh what about that fourth
commandment that says remember the
Sabbath to keep it holy. What is that
all about? Take a look at the website.
It's just simply sabbathtruth.com.
sabbathtruth.com.
A lot of great information.
Yeah. And uh Rita will be happy to send
you we have a special study guide on the
Sabbath if you call Amazing Facts. It's
the uh lost day of history. That's
right. The number to call is
800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book called The Lost
Day of History. In 800-835-6747,
ask for the study guide The Lost Day of
History.
Our next caller is James and he's
listening in Dallas, Texas. James,
welcome to the program.
Yes. Hello. Hi James, thanks for
calling.
Yeah, my question is well, in
Revelations uh when it talks about the
last judgment, it says that those who
were not found in the book of life
uh
uh were sent to the lake of fire. That
gives me an indication that as it reads,
sounds like that someone
uh was found in the book of life at the
last judgment. Is that right or
Well, yeah, you know, Moses prayed
and he said, "Lord, if you won't forgive
Israel, then take my name out of your
book." So, evidently Moses' name is one
of those who are written in the book of
life and
evidence for that would be Moses
actually appears to Jesus
uh along with Elijah, so their names are
both in the book of life cuz they're
already in heaven.
And so uh there there are people whose
names are written in the book of life.
Now, in the great white throne judgment,
some people have their names entered
into the book of life
and they can be excluded if they are
found to be unfaithful.
And uh in Revelation chapter 2 or 3, one
of the messages to the seven churches,
Jesus said
uh something about taking their name
from the book of life speaking of the a
church that was unfaithful.
So, Uh Yeah, people can have their names
entered and evidently through persistent
rebellion, it could be stricken from the
book,
so to speak. Mhm.
But yeah, the names of the redeemed, I
think, those who have reached out in
faith
through the ages to trusting in the
blood of the lamb,
uh if you're in the Old Testament, they
knew it was the Messiah that was coming.
For us, it's the Messiah who came.
Um
we have our names entered in the book of
life.
Okay. Well, yeah, I was I was wondering
being at the last judgment that uh well,
of course, uh believers have their name
written there.
Um
I guess what I'm saying is after the
first uh judgment seat of Christ,
uh
all the all the
all those who belong to Christ will be
judged there.
And and the way it reads for the last
judgment is that there would be some
after the um
uh uh seven-year tribulation,
there would be some that would be saved.
Well, let Pastor Ross has a verse on
that he's going to read you. Yeah, you
were just talking about the names being
blotted out of the book of life.
Revelation chapter 3 verse 5. And this
is the one that Pastor Doug was
referring to. He says, "He who overcomes
shall be clothed in white garment."
Talking about the redeemed, the saved.
"I will not blot his name from the book
of life, but I'll confess his name
before my father which is in heaven."
So, in heaven, there are different
books. You've got a book of life which
those who are redeemed, their names in
the book. But you also have a book of um
iniquity, those who have done evil deeds
and uh are unrepentant. Yeah. The works
are judged It says we're we're judged
according to our works. So, somewhere
those works are recorded.
Sure. And and there would be those evil
works that the wicked have done.
So, um yeah, there is a record in
heaven.
And then there it says, "The judgment
was set and the books were opened." I
don't know if God uses a a book made
with a leather binding and and a paper
pulp. I mean, you know, exactly how the
books are recorded in heaven may be
different from what we have on earth,
but there's a record is what God is
saying.
That was their system of reckoning in
those days. Now, we do have a lesson
we'll hap- be happy to send you, James.
It talks about facing the judge.
And if you call the resource line, we'll
send that to you for free. The number
again is 800-835-6747.
That is the resource phone number and
you can ask for the study guide called
Facing the Judge. It's talking about the
judgment. How we can make sure our names
remain in the Lamb's Book of Life. If
you have a Bible question, the phone
line here to the studio is 800-463-7297.
800-463-7297.
Uh with your Bible question. Our next
caller is Gary listening in Arkansas.
Gary, welcome to the program.
Uh good evening. How are y'all doing
tonight? Doing well.
My question has to deal with uh I
experienced a near-death experience
in a surgery.
And is there any way in the Bible where
it shows that God showed people
or someone what hell was like in order
to get them to change their ways and uh
to turn around and start serving him
more?
Well, there's no scripture that says
that God showed somebody hell other than
what um John saw in Revelation.
It is entirely possible that God could
communicate personally to an individual
about an experience
uh in a dream for you know, God could
give a dream to someone to impress them.
Um
Yeah. You have the experience where Paul
says, "I knew a man
who was caught up to the third heaven."
And um
Paul's probably talking about himself.
And he saw things that you know, he
can't even talk about.
Uh so, we don't even know what Paul saw
when he was caught up to the third
heaven. It was something between God and
Paul.
So, God can give anybody a personal
experience, but we must not base our
theology
upon a dream or an experience or a
near-death experience a person may have
on the operating table or following an
accident.
Because you know, I think we all know
all over the world people have all kinds
of dreams and experiences and if our
theology is based on everybody's dream,
we got to base it on the word of God.
There needs to be a a solid, unchanging
source of truth.
Otherwise, boy, we'll be carried around
with every wind of doctrine. Everybody
will be having dreams. Some will be
real, some will be manufactured.
Yeah.
I understand that. Okay. Well, thank you
very much.
All right, good question. Appreciate
that, Gary.
Our next caller is uh Maureen listening
in New York. And um we have Maureen,
welcome to the program.
Hello. Can you hear me? We can. Let's
get started on your question and we
might have to take a break before we're
done.
Oh, okay.
Um yes. What I would like to know is I
know it's from the New Testament, but I
don't know what exact verse it is.
Uh it is appointed unto man once to die
and then the judgment.
Um my
is my question is what exactly is meant
by appointed?
Well, that's meaning and it's found in
the book of Hebrews that everybody is
going to have to face death and then in
the resurrection, there's a judgment.
Yeah, that's Hebrews 9:27 is the verse.
Yep. Okay.
So, Okay. Hey, I'll tell you what,
Maureen, if you could hold on, when we
come back after the break, we'll talk
more about it. Thank you.
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return in a moment.
I love the quote, "The greatest want of
the world is the want of men. Men who
will stand for the right though the
heavens fall." Yet studies are showing
for several years now, the secular media
and culture have sought to portray men
as the family idiots.
Sadly, respect for the role of fathers
and husbands has reached an all-time
low. So now, as the disspirited men
abandon their roles of godly leadership,
it's not surprising that we're
experiencing a moral free fall in our
country.
That's why starting September 30th, I'll
be presenting a new program called
Mighty Men of God. Using biblical
principles, this encouraging four-part
series will address how to be a loving
father, faithful husband, and all-round
man of God in the family, church, and
nation.
Please plan to join Pastor Doug
Batchelor starting September 30th at
7:00 p.m. Pacific Standard Time. For
more information about this live event,
please go to amazingfacts.org.
Again, that's amazingfacts.org.
Can't get enough Amazing Facts Bible
Study? You don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth-filled
programming.
Visit the Amazing Facts Media Library at
aftv.org.
At aftv.org,
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge, 24 hours a
day, 7 days a week, right from your
computer or mobile device. Visit
aftv.org.
Every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life.
So, what are you waiting for? Get the
answers you need for a fuller, richer,
more confident life.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. If you'd like answers to your
Bible-related questions on the air,
please call us next Sunday between 7:00
p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific Time. To
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program,
call 800-835-6747.
Once again, that's 800-835-6747.
Now, let's join Pastors Doug Batchelor
and Jean Ross for more Bible Answers
Live.
Uh if you have a Bible question as
Pastor Doug mentioned, we do have some
phone lines open. Uh if you would like
to get your question on the air, good
time to give us a call right now. It's
800-463-7297.
And just before the break, we were
talking with Maureen in New York.
Maureen, you're back on the air. Yes.
Yes. Um
it it it implies to me that um we are
birth on our um birth, our life, our
death is pre- predestined, predetermined
by God.
Well, for, you know, 99.9999%
of people,
as that old adage says, few things are
as certain as death and taxes.
People grow old, statistically, and we
end up dying.
And after that, the judgment. So, Paul
is saying this life is short, and during
this life, we're deciding how we're
going to spend eternity.
Now, there'll be a short there'll be a
small exception. Of course, Elijah went
to heaven in a fiery chariot. Enoch was
translated without dying. It says he
walked with God and God took him. And
some will be alive when Jesus comes that
will not die. It says we are transformed
and caught up to meet the Lord in the
air. That's 1 Thessalonians chapter 4.
So, are are you troubled by the idea
that we are predestined to die, most
people?
Um
It's not really predestined. It's a
consequence.
by that verse. Yeah, I mean, it's not
that God arbitrary says you're going to
die today, and there's nothing you can
do about it. Otherwise, why would he
tell us to take care of our bodies and
live healthy lives. Uh but ultimately,
um everyone will die if Christ does not
come before they they die. So, there is
a day when our our life will be over,
our probation will close.
And uh then Paul is saying the next
thing is the judgment.
Yeah, and that that's an appeal that
Paul is making that we can all prepare
for what they call the day of the Lord
when uh
eternal destinies will be awarded based
on
our faith in this life, and if we've uh
followed the Lord.
Okay, I think you've answered my
question. I do thank you very much. All
right, thank you, Maureen. Appreciate
your call, and and uh look forward to
hearing from you again. We have uh
Esther listening in Michigan. Esther,
welcome to the program. I have a
question about what are
the food that are
um okay to eat. Like, I mean, meat. I'm
referring
to
Yeah, so in
I heard, and I'm not sure.
The The Bible has a few passages. Of
course, the original diet for man was a
vegetarian diet. And then after that, um
after sin, God added vegetables, and
then after the flood, the Lord said, you
know, if you're going to eat meat, then
make sure that you eat what they called
the clean meats. There were some animals
that principally were vegetarians, and
their diet was a little safer. And God
did not want us eating things that were
scavengers. And you know, there you've
got things like skunks and dogs and pigs
and vultures.
So, uh those things were declared
unclean. Now, there's three rules.
There's so many different animals. You
say, "Well,
you know, is there a big long list of
animals?" Well, some of them are listed
in the book of Ezekiel.
But uh there are three rules. The The
fish that were clean to eat needed two
characteristics: fins and scales. If
they had fins and scales, they were safe
to eat.
The animals or mammals, they needed to
have a cloven hoof, a split hoof like a
deer or cow or a goat, and chew the cud.
That's where they've got, you know, a
very elaborate digestive system. They
eat grass, they chew it up, they swallow
it, and then they might re- chew it and
then swallow it again.
And um
the they were clean among the animals.
And among the birds, it was the foraging
birds. Those are the birds like turkey
and chicken and quail and dove, and they
go around, they pick through seeds and
bugs,
and they forage. Not your birds of
carrion or your raptors. They were
unclean.
And so, uh
science is pretty well established that
if a person's going to eat meat, you're
a lot better off
uh eating the meats that God designated
as safe or clean.
By the way, it's also true that you
could never offer an unclean animal in
the sanctuary. That was considered an
abomination.
And our bodies are the temple of the
Holy Spirit. So, hey, you know, Esther,
we do have a book that talks about some
of the health laws you'd find in the
Bible, and I think it's called God's
Free Health Plan. We'll send you a free
copy. All you have to do is just give us
a call on our resource phone number. The
number is 800-835-6747.
And ask for the Amazing Facts study
guide on health. It's called God's Free
Health Plan. It's one of our favorite
studies. It's very practical. It's got
some great biblical principles. Again,
that number is 800-835-6747.
Ask for the study guide called God's
Free Health Plan. We'll be happy to send
that to you, Esther, or anyone who calls
and asks. Our next caller is Let's see,
we've got
Holly on uh listening in Ontario. Holly,
welcome to the program.
Holly, you there?
Hi, thank you for calling and your
question tonight.
Um
I want to know what
um
You said blasphemy?
Yes, what is blasphemy against the Holy
Spirit?
Yeah, blasphemy is when a person speaks
something
that is considered um
uh sacrilegious. Usually, they are
sayings they're putting themself in the
place of God or putting someone else in
the place of God,
and that was called blasphemous.
Um blasphemy against the Holy Spirit,
and the reason many people ask this
question is because it says it's the one
sin that cannot be forgiven, is when a
person basically puts themself in the
place of God, and they refuse to listen
to the Holy Spirit when God's spirit
brings conviction. And if we continue to
grieve away the Holy Spirit,
the Holy Spirit is the person of the
Godhead
that is instrumental
in softening our hearts and leading us
to God. And if we resist that, there's
nothing God can do to save us. It's
That's why it's a sin that can't be
forgiven,
because it's a sin we refuse to repent
of.
You still there? Yeah.
You know, we do have a book, Holly.
We'll be happy to send you a free copy
about what is the unpardonable sin. Are
you worried that you've committed that
sin?
No, I'm just wondering because
um
I've
I have a Bible, and
it's an NIV, and it's
a different from
Sometimes a little harder to understand,
maybe, huh?
Yeah. Yeah, you know, one of the
versions that I like, I think Pastor
Ross uses frequently, is called the New
King James Version. Of course, we love
the King James Version. New King James
is a little more modern English, but
it's pretty much the same translation,
so it's going to be familiar.
Uh some of the translations are
you know, they became very um creative.
And uh some of the verses don't even
sound the same
when they translated it from the
original. So,
um you might find that it's easier to
understand in one of those translations
like the King James and the New King
James.
Yeah, appreciate your call. We do have a
book that talks about uh what is the
unpardonable sin. It's called Beyond
Mercy.
The number to call is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book entitled Beyond
Mercy, and we'll be happy to send that
out to you, Holly, or anybody who calls
and asks. Again, that number is
800-835-6747.
And the phone line here to the studio,
if you have a Bible question, is
800-463-7297.
We have uh Sabra listening from New
York. Sabra, welcome to the program.
Oh, yes. Hi, Pastor Doug and Pastor
Shawn. Thanks for taking my call. Uh my
question is um
I'm I just got baptized over a month
ago, and I've been Wow, it's I've had
the
the experience of joy and peace and all
the happy stuff. And now, it seems like
I've
um I'm struggling with knowing when God
is leading me or not, or if I'm doing my
own works, and I'm also having a
difficulty judging others, and I'm
trying How do I not judge others, and
when do I speak to them, and when do I
not? And
I'm just all over the place. Well, first
of all, congratulations, and you'll
never regret the decision to to come to
Jesus.
Do not be discouraged if there are
challenges and temptations and
questions. Jesus had the devil come to
him after his baptism to get him to
doubt his faith.
You remember in the wilderness Christ
was tempted after his baptism.
Uh and so sometimes we are attacked and
there's some confusion. Don't just hang
on and you'll get through you'll get
through the rapids and there'll be calm
water again.
Um
but uh you
in each case the first of all the Bible
doesn't say it's never right to judge.
Even Jesus said when you judge use a
righteous judgment. Uh we shouldn't
judge and condemn people but God wants
us to use good judgment and
Paul even said to the Corinthian church
he said look you're going to judge
angels can't you judge small matters?
So when there was disputes among the
members Paul said the church should
judge those things and not take it to
secular courts.
So it's not wrong to use judgment. You
always want to pray that you'll have
grace and do it like Jesus would.
Um now what was your other question you
were asking?
Uh I want to make sure that I'm being
how can I know that God is leading me
and and I'm not doing my own works? Well
you may not always feel
that you know the the Holy Spirit has a
leash on you.
Um
but as long as you're asking those
questions it means you're sensitive to
the spirit which is very good.
Measure what you're doing by the word.
Um you will have the inner voice of the
spirit.
And the Bible talks about that. Get
Christian counsel.
Uh when you have Christians and you you
can talk to them and in the multitude of
Christian counsel there's safety.
And look for the providence of how God
leads you. God will sometimes you'll see
him intervene in your life in amazing
ways. Doors will open and doors will
close and if you say Lord I'm willing to
do your will he'll guide you.
You know we have a book
that I think you'll find very helpful.
It's called Determining the Will of God
and it deals with this very subject.
What are some of the things we ought to
look for
in order to know yeah is this what God
wants me to do and I some great
principles there. And we'll be happy to
send this to you Sabre if you just give
us a call on our resource phone number
and ask for the book called Determining
the Will of God. The number to call is
800-835-6747.
Ask for the book Determining the Will of
God and we'll be happy to send it to you
or anybody who calls and asks. Amen.
Our next caller is John listening from
San Diego. John welcome to the program.
Hello pastor are you there? We are.
Thank you for calling John.
Yeah I've been enjoying the show for a
little over a year. Appreciate it. Have
a lot of fun listening to it and learn a
lot. I'm a long time Christian and I
just had one question that I
you seem to keep popping back into my
mind every once in a while and it is
what is the meaning of the verse
Be still and know that I am God. Is that
verse meant for individual Christians or
individual people or was it meant in a
context
in some biblical
uh narrative that it really doesn't
pertain to people
in this day and age?
Well no I think it applies to every
believer and you find that in Psalm 46
verse 10 if I'm not mistaken.
But um you you also can look for
instance in Psalm 4:4 and David says
there meditate within your heart on your
bed and be still. Being still means
don't be anxious. It's like Jesus said
fear not. Paul says be anxious about
nothing. When the children of Israel
were at the Red Sea God said stand still
and see the salvation of the Lord. And
so sometimes God just basically said
look I'm I'm in charge I'll take care of
you. Trust me.
And so this appeal of being still meant
be at peace. Trust me.
Uh you know that's what Jesus did to the
storm. He said be
be
be still be at peace and the storm
calmed down.
You know the Bible also says be anxious
for nothing meaning that we ought to
take all of our cares
and place it be- before the Lord in
prayer and then trust in his leading and
his providence.
Mhm.
Yes I like that. It's almost like a
meditation of sorts and uh
I when I in in at times I do get a
certain
uh peace almost like I'm letting God
catch up with me
in my in my hectic life you know.
You know someone told me once I've not
done the count myself but I believe it's
true. I think it was Dwight Moody
counted that there are 365 times in the
Bible when the Lord says be
uh peace or or be at peace
uh and or fear not.
And the God doesn't want us to live in
fear or anxiety or stress.
And
you know often angels showed up and
people were terrified and they said
peace.
Even when Jesus came into the world the
angels said peace and goodwill.
And so there in Psalm 46 be still and
know that I'm God. Be at peace.
And uh
God is not wringing his hands wondering
what he's going to do.
He is uh 100% in control and he's not
anxious about anything. He doesn't want
us to be.
Hey thank you very much John for your
question and
don't know if we don't really have a
book on Well you know Determining the
Will of God might be helpful as well cuz
it does talk about how do we have that
peace in our heart when we are trusting
in the Lord to lead.
The number to call for that free
resource is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book called
Determining the Will of God.
Our next caller is Marty listening from
Savannah in Tennessee. Marty welcome to
the program.
Hey how are you tonight?
Doing well. How can we help you?
Oh good good. I have a question for you
here.
Um my question is it it says in the New
Testament that uh
uh and my question is on baptism. Yeah.
And it says that he that believes and is
baptized shall be saved.
And then it also states further on that
uh
call upon the name of the Lord and you
shall be saved.
So I just have a little confusion with
that. Do you think you might be able to
clarify that up for me?
Yeah well are you wondering what the
criteria for salvation is? Well is it is
it part is baptism part of the plan of
salvation? Well certainly baptism is
part of the plan. I mean the last words
of Jesus were go teach and baptize.
And when the disciples when the
people of Israel said to the disciples
what do we do
uh they said repent and be baptized
every one of you.
Um and of course it's in in
John chapter 3 he that is born of the
water and the spirit.
Unless you're born of the water and the
spirit you cannot enter the kingdom of
heaven. It's very important. So now
Jesus isn't saying there'll be nobody in
heaven unless they were baptized because
that would you know eliminate a lot of
Old Testament characters.
But baptism is as important to a
Christian
as a wedding is to a marriage.
Baptism is the ceremony. It is the
right. It's the covenant in which we're
publicly saying we accept this
forgiveness of Jesus sins and want our
sins washed away.
But there'll be people in heaven like
the thief on the cross who could not be
baptized and of course you know Christ
will give him credit for his baptism.
Jesus was not baptized for his sin. He
was baptized as an example for us.
So yeah baptism is important. It is not
that you have to be baptized you can't
be saved.
But if you are saved you'll want to be
baptized cuz the Lord commands it.
We have a book called Baptism Is It
Really Necessary? And it gets to this
very subject and I think you'll find
this interesting Marty.
Again if you'd like to receive this book
just call us on our resource phone
number and that number is 800-835-6747.
We'll be happy to send you the book. You
can also read it for free online at the
Amazing Facts website.
Just amazingfacts.org.
Amen. Thank you Marty.
Our next caller is
Nelson listening from Washington state.
Nelson welcome to the program.
Hello how are you?
Good. Thank you for calling.
Yes thank you for having me. Um
I have a question. Uh I was reading the
Bible and I read the verse that says
basically one Lord one faith one
baptism. Mhm.
So that got me thinking
why are there so many churches if
there's supposed to be just one faith
one Lord one baptism?
Yeah the Lord only wants one Lord one
faith one baptism.
Matter of fact in John 17 Jesus said in
his prayer all men will know you're my
disciples by your love for one another.
Well if you were the devil and you heard
Jesus say that you'd think well if
everybody's going to believe by their
unity I'll try and divide them as much
as I can.
And there is no religion in the world
that has more different fragments and
divisions than Christianity
by far. I mean there are a lot of
divisions in Hinduism and there's many
divisions in Islam.
But Christianity takes the cake. There
are like thousand different
denominations.
And so are sects and um
that doesn't mean there isn't a truth
out there.
And many of the churches would overlap
on the primary teachings of the Bible.
But
and the devil's been you know the best
way to hide a diamond
is if you throw it in a pile of broken
glass.
And the devil is trying to hide the
diamond of truth
that Christ gave to his people
by fragmenting it and hiding it a bunch
amongst a bunch of counterfeits so it's
it's hard to spot.
So yeah unfortunately there are a lot of
divisions of Christianity but that
doesn't mean there's only one. There is
one truth, one Lord, one faith, one
baptism.
You know, we do have a book called The
Search for the True Church.
Really dealing with some biblical
principles when we're looking for a
church. What are some of the guidelines
that the Bible gives? Well, we'd be
happy to send this to you, Nelson, or
anybody wanting to learn more about
this. The number to call is
800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book called The
Search for the True Church. Again, that
number is 800-835-6747.
Our next caller is Dominic listening
from New York. Dominic, you're on the
air.
Yes, thank you,
uh, Pastor Doug, for doing what you do.
Well, thank you for calling.
My question
is, uh, in view of God's omniscience,
uh,
and this is a question to you. Do you
think that,
uh, he could have done or he could do a
better job
of, uh,
making himself known and what he wants?
Since God well, since you say he's
omniscience is he's all-knowing,
uh,
also could say God's omnipotence, but
uh, obviously I'm, you know, I'm not
going to say, "God, I've got some advice
for you."
There you've got the creature telling
the creation, the creator, how to run
things. And that that would kind of be
backwards. All right, I know it is, uh,
uh, But there's a there's reasons. Man
has mankind has sort of separated
himself from God.
And the Bible promises that if you
search for me, you'll find me if you
search for me with all your heart.
God wants us to love him. He wants us to
want him.
This world has, for the most part, uh,
rejected God and and the devil sort of
has hijacked the planet, but Jesus came
into the world. God was in Christ
reconciling the world to himself.
The Lord wants to save as many as he
can.
And so, uh,
you know, if we want to see God,
you know, you can sometimes see the Lord
in a newborn baby or in a beautiful
sunset
or in, uh, the things of nature and
and the evidence for God is everywhere.
So, I think he is making himself known.
Uh, in other words, couldn't he have
couldn't he do a better job?
Could God do a better job?
Yes, of of making himself known and,
uh, what he wants so that we wouldn't
have,
uh, unbelievers.
Well, you know, I believe that God God
doesn't want to force anybody to believe
in him.
And if he wanted to, you know, the Lord
could suddenly appear in the heavens.
And from what I read in the Bible, if
God appeared to us right now in his
unveiled glory, we could not handle it.
And that's why Jesus came into the world
so that he could reveal God to us,
veiled in humanity,
so we could say, "What is God like? Who
is he?" And Jesus said, "If you've seen
me, you've seen the Father."
He came to show us what God is like.
And, you know, in the Bible, we've got
the record of his life and his love for
us. And, uh, it's pretty clear
uh, who Christ is and what he's like.
So, uh, you know, I I would never say
God could do a better job. I'm sure in
our minds we could imagine
the Lord doing something like that, but
that's why we've got to be careful cuz
in the last days I think the devil's
going to try to impersonate God.
And if our faith is not in the word,
we'll fall for the counterfeit.
You know, Jesus, when he was here on the
earth, he performed all kinds of
miracles, even raising the dead.
And yet that didn't convince those who
were just stubbornly refusing to
believe.
I'm thinking of the religious leaders in
particular.
Jesus said they won't believe even if
someone was raised from the dead. And of
course, he did raise people from the
dead and they still didn't change. So,
even if God was to do something, you
know, extraordinary, uh, to reveal
himself, those who refuse to believe
will still refuse to believe. Yeah.
Well, friends, you hear the music coming
up. We're going to be wrapping the
program in a little bit, but don't go
away because following this
announcement, we do have another amazing
fact for you.
So, stand by and uh, don't forget also
there's a lot more you can see at the
website, which is
simplyamazingfacts.org.
Check out the new Rapture Truth website.
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before.
Bible Answers Live is produced by
Amazing Facts, a faith-based ministry
located in Sacramento, California.
I love the quote, "The greatest want of
the world is the want of men. Men who
will stand for the right though the
heavens fall." Yet studies are showing
for several years now, the secular media
and culture have sought to portray men
as the family idiots. Sadly, respect for
the role of fathers and husbands has
reached an all-time low. So now, as the
dispirited men abandon their roles of
godly leadership, it's not surprising
that we're experiencing a moral freefall
in our country.
That's why starting September 30, I'll
be presenting a new program called
Mighty Men of God. Using biblical
principles, this encouraging four-part
series will address how to be a loving
father, faithful husband, and all-around
man of God in the family, church, and
nation.
Please plan to join Pastor Doug
Batchelor starting September 30th at
7:00 p.m. Pacific Standard Time. For
more information about this live event,
please go to amazingfacts.org.
Again, that's amazingfacts.org.
Have you ever heard a mouse howl like a
wolf?
Well, what would you expect would happen
when a creature changes its destiny from
the hapless prey to mighty predator?
From the outside, they look very much
like just an oversized field mouse.
Cute brown fur, white on the underbelly,
nice little beady eyes, but that's where
the similarity stop. Grasshopper mice
are very unusual, making them the
objects of great interest for animal
researchers.
These furry little creatures are found
in the harsh deserts of North America.
They're very territorial in nature and
they will monopolize and fend off 25
acres. They don't build their own homes,
but sort of confiscate the burrows and
the homes of other creatures.
They're not called grasshopper mice cuz
they hop around, but it's because they
eat a lot of grasshoppers. In fact,
scientists have discovered grasshopper
mice are the only mice that are purely
carnivorous.
They hunt much like cats or weasels,
stalking their prey in a predatory
fashion. And when they pounce, they are
ferocious, sometimes even taking on
snakes and scorpions and centipedes.
When a grasshopper mouse gets into a
fierce battle with a snake or a scorpion
or centipede, they may be bit or stung
several times.
But what is amazing to researchers is
they've noticed when they are bitten,
they somehow shake it off because they
convert the toxin in the venom to
painkiller.
I think you can understand why this
information would be of special interest
to scientists that are trying to
discover new ways for people to deal
with chronic pain.
One of the most intriguing
characteristics of these little
creatures is when they're defending
their territory or celebrating a victory
over some adversary,
they'll throw back their head and let
out this earth-shaking howl.
It's a mousy howl. Check it out.
The grasshopper mouse is not the only
member of creation that can survive
encounters with venomous predators.
In Luke 10:19, it says, "Behold, I will
give you authority to trample on
serpents and scorpions and over all the
power of the enemy. Nothing will by any
means hurt you."
We don't have to be the biggest and the
strongest to defeat our enemy and let
out that victory roar.
When God called David to be king, no
human would have guessed that he had it
in him. He was young and insignificant.
From the outside, he looked like there
was no greatness in him.
But when God looked at his heart, he saw
courage, humility, compassion, and love.
David wasn't perfect and he made
mistakes, but through God's power, he
was able to conquer giants.
Friend, God does not intend that you
live out the rest of your life cowering
and trembling like a little field mouse.
If God can take the grasshopper mouse
and give him courage so that he fights
snakes and scorpions and centipedes,
if God can put in the heart of David the
courage to fight giants like Goliath,
then he can give you that same courage.
The scripture say God has not given you
the spirit of fear, but of power, love,
and a sound mind. And you can have that
peace in your heart when you invite the
prince of peace in your heart. Why don't
you do that right now?
For over 50 years, Amazing Facts has
shared the wonderful news of salvation
and provided millions of Bible resources
to people all over the world. We built
churches in India, proclaimed God's word
in China, and have sent free Bible
studies around the globe.
Today's program and free resources were
made possible by our ministry partners,
caring individuals like you.
If you've been blessed by Amazing Facts,
would you please consider partnering
with us to reach others with the Bible
truth?
Your financial support today will help
keep programs like this on the air, so
the blessings you've received can be
shared with others.
To find out more about becoming a
ministry partner, please visit our
website at amazingfacts.org.